you put up an Instagram photo and it has
an interesting option yes this is you
and it says yeah it says ninth grade
notice the pointy head and then you said
got beat up the day before with my own
shoes yeah is that first of all is that
true that's a true story yeah I was uh I
was at Alerus I was always hilarious to
get beat up with your own shoes yeah I
was beat up with an earring yeah thank
you dr. Freud yeah I was at it I was at
I was at the bowling alley playing
pinball I I was on my way home I
realized are we what part of the world
in Philly I grew up in Philly yeah I
realized that I was you know gonna gonna
be mugged I was being chased I went
through this parking lot thinking that
it was a shortcut to my house and I
thought I would make it be able to make
it home faster or whatever so they
caught me in the parking lot and I gave
him you know my money was just what I'd
do if I get mugged and there the viewers
at home yeah if you're watching I'll
give it up yeah no problem no problem
and then they had this idea that I might
have had some stuff and some stuff some
money in my shoes in my socks and my
shoes or whatever so they asked me to
take off my shoes so I took off my shoes
and I was you know showing them but I
didn't have any money there and all of a
sudden BAM I get smacked right across
the head and at the back of the head and
I had thought to myself but when when I
was first being mugged well nobody's got
sticks which is always good that's kind
of like what you we used to look for
because such innocent times yeah no
one's got sticks I'm in the clear yeah
and and then I realized that the guy was
just beat beating me silly with my own
shoes they had they were kind of like
these you know had little heel on them
and there's it's it would hurt but then
there's a level of humiliation - you
can't be beaten with your own shoe there
is nothing more humiliating than being
beaten with your own shoes except maybe
someone's girlfriend being nauseous when
she sees you yeah those two things I
would say are right up there